cómo lo has planteado en un inicio el
presidente quería que la gente decidiera
si se debe enjuiciar a los expresidentes
es ahí cuando surgió la controversia
pues los críticos
argumentaban que la justicia no se
somete a consulta y que la ley se debe
aplicar si existen delitos que perseguir
independientemente de la opinión de la
ciudadanía tras la modificación de la
suprema corte a la redacción de la
pregunta
presidente y más que el presidente de
los partidarios de él legisladores
simpatizantes promovieron hasta el
último momento la idea entre la
población de que se trata de saber si se
enjuicia a expresidentes y también esta
promoción pues fue acompañada de
imágenes de los ex mandatarios desde
carlos salinas hasta ernesto zedillo y
enrique peña nieto- esto provocó la
polémica principalmente mario que
permitiría esta consulta en caso de ser
aprobada y qué pasa si es aprobada pero
no con una participación suficiente para
que sea vinculante
definitivamente necesita participar
alrededor de 37 millones de mexicanos
para que sea vinculante pero vinculante
para quien es el presidente de la
suprema corte ha aclarado que no
derivaría ningún momento en procesos
judiciales pero si en la posible
creación de comisiones de la verdad esto
tendría que llevarlas a cabo el poder
legislativo y el poder ejecutivo para
conocer qué fue lo que ocurrió y aplicar
mecanismos de justicia transicional es
decir reparación del daño y garantías de
no repetición esto sin duda pues es un
ejercicio inédito que independientemente
de que sea vinculante o no ya es algo
histórico y el partido del presidente
los legisladores han dicho que llevarán
a cabo estas comisiones de la verdad
-mario gracias por toda la información
feliz resto de día